[Randall]
Die ersten Worte, die jemals ein Mensch auf dem Mond
gesprochen hat, kennt wohl jeder.
That's one small step for a man
one giant leap for mankind.
Aber, wie sieht's aus mit den letzten Worten?
As we leave the moon at Taurus-Littrow,
we leave as we came
And, God willing, as we shall return
with peace and hope
for all mankind.
00:00:32,000 --> 00:00:36,000
[Randall]
Das war am 14.Dezember 1972.
Seitdem, 50 Jahre später, hat kein Mensch
den Mond mehr betreten.
Die Artemis-Mission der NASA
soll das bald ändern.
Diese Pläne der NASA gibt's seit Ewigkeiten.
Warum dauert das so lange?
Warum ist es so schwierig
Menschen auf den Mond zu schießen?
[Intro]
Beim Apollo-Mondprogramm der NASA, in den Sechzigern,
war das Hauptziel v.a. die Sowiets auszustechen.
Und als erste auf dem Mond zu landen.
[Aufnahmen der Apollo-11-Mission]
Als es dann geschafft war, ließ das Interesse
und damit auch das Forschungsbudget drastisch nach.
Andere Forschungsziele wurden wichtiger.
Aber in den letzten Jahren
ist der Mond wieder in den Fokus gerückt
Und zwar nicht nur bei den Amerikanern,
sondern weltweit.
Denn es wird vermutet, dass dort
wertvolle Rohstoffe existieren könnten,
die man vielleicht abbauen kann und
zur Erde transportieren kann.
Was ich persönlich viel interessanter finde,
Ist das wir jetzt zum Mond zurückkehren wollen
nicht nur um dort spazieren zu gehen,
sondern um dort zu bleiben
Und eventuell eine Mondkolonie aufzubauen.
Und der Mond könnte als Basis genutzt werden
für Expeditionen weiter hinaus in den Weltraum
wie zum Beispiel zum Mars.
Aber zuerst müssen wir mal zurück zum Mond kommen.
Und das ist das erklärte Ziel
des Artemis-Programms der NASA.
Artemis ist die Mondgöttin
und die Zwillingsschwester von Apollon.
Der Name passt also sehr gut.
Das Programm, soll wie auch das Apollo-Programm,
aus mehreren Missionen bestehen.
Artemis I soll schon bald starten.
Das wird eine unbemannte Mission
bei der das neue Trägerraketenraumschiffssystem
getestet werden soll.
Und zwar, soll die Orion-Raumkapsel
zusammen mit der SLS-Trägerrakete starten,
dann wird die Raumkapsel einmal
zum Mondtransfer gebracht,
einmal rund um den Mond fliegen,
zurück zu Erde kommen
und dann hoffentlich weich im Ozean landen.
Die Orion-Kapsel bietet Platz für vier Astronauten
und wurde großteils von den Amerikanern gebaut,
aber es gibt auch eine europäische Komponente:
Das Service-Modul, hier.
Das wurde in Deutschland gebaut.
Übrigens, ganz ohne Besatzung
wird Orion auch beim ersten Testflug nicht sein.
Es sind nämlich 4 Legofiguren mit an Bord.
Die erste Artemis-Mission mit menschlicher
Besatzung an Bord wird Artemis II.
Die soll frühestens 2024 starten.
Und dabei wird die Kapsel mit den Astronauten an Bord
so Richtung Mond geschossen, dass
im Falle eines Triebwerksausfalls die Kapsel
von der Schwerkraft des Mondes umgelenkt wird
und von selber wieder zurück zur Erde kommt.
Wenn das alles gut läuft,
dann kommt das Apollo 11 unserer Generation:
Artemis III, die Mondlandung mit Menschen an Bord.
Dazu wird, mit dem SLS das Orion-Raumschiff,
erst in den Erdorbit und dann bis zum Mondorbit gebracht.
Dort soll es dann mit dem Starship
zusammentreffen, was im Mondorbit wartet.
Das Starship wird dann auf dem Mond landen,
die Astronauten absetzten für eine Woche ungefähr,
dann wieder starten.
Die Astronauten werden wieder in
das Orion-Raumschiff verfrachtet
und fliegen schön zur Erde zurück.
Ganz besonders toll finde ich,
dass mit der Mission zum ersten Mal
eine Frau und eine person of colour
auf dem Mond landen sollen.
Das ganze Programm ist allerdings,
wie in der Raumfahrtbranche üblich, total verspätet.
Eigentlich hat Präsident Trump angekündigt, dass
noch während seiner zweiten Amtszeit
die erste Amerikanerin auf dem Mond landen sollte.
"Make the moon great again" sozusagen.
Das hat nicht geklappt.
Wieso ist es so schwierig zurück zum Mond zu kommen?
Wir waren vor 50 Jahren schon mal da
und wir sind technologisch jetzt so viel weiter.
Wenn man sich den Apollo Board-Computer anschaut,
dann könnten wir heute nur müde darüber lächeln.
Jedes normale Smartphone hat die millionenfache
Rechenleistung, wie damals der Apollo-Bordcomputer.
Das müsste also relativ einfach sein,
wieder zum Mond zu kommen.
Eines der Hauptprobleme sind die Kosten.
Die NASA hat das Gesamtbudget der Mission
auf 86 Mrd.$ hochgerechnet.
Das ist mehr als Doppel so viel
wie ursprünglich eingeplant.
Zum Vergleich, die Apollo-Mission hat damals,
wenn man das in die heutige Währung umrechnet,
112 Mrd.$ verschlungen.
Also nochmal ein bisschen mehr.
Allerdings stand der NASA damals 4%
des gesamten US-Budgets zur Verfügung.
Davon kann die NASA heute nur träumen.
Außerdem braucht man, wenn wir zum Mond
zurückwollen, eine leistungsstarke Rakete.
Damals, während der Apollo-Mission,
hatten wir die Saturn V.
Die kann aber jetzt nicht 1:1 nachgebaut werden.
Das Problem ist nämlich,
dass die Saturn V in Züge der Apollo-Mission
immer wieder leicht adjustiert
und verändert wurde.
Und diese ganzen Änderungen
sind nicht ausreichend dokumentiert.
Außerdem ist natürlich die Expertise,
die damals vor 50 Jahren gab, verloren gegangen.
Das andere Problem ist, dass damals
viele Komponenten wie z.B. Schrauben
einfach aus dem Katalog bestellt wurden
und diese Kataloge gibt es auch nicht mehr
50 Jahre später.
Und die Sicherheitsstandards
sind heute natürlich ganz andere.
Das ist natürlich erstmal gut.
Die Saturn V war eine dreistufige Rakete,
im Vergleich zu den heute meist
zweistufigen Raketen, die verwendet werden.
Die dreistufige Rakete hat einen Vorteil,
dass sie energetisch sehr viel effizienter ist,
um große Nutzlasten bis in den Erdorbit
und bis zum Mond zu bringen,
aber eine dreistufige Rakete ist im Vergleich
zu den zweistufigen Raketen viel anfälliger.
Deswegen hat die NASA in den letzten Jahren
ein neues Raketen-System entwickelt:
Die SLS: das Space Lauch System.
Sie ist ein bisschen kleiner,
als die riesige Saturn V mit 110 m.
Und sie ist sogar
ein kleines Bisschen leistungsstärker.
Was interessant ist, ist, dass beim SLS
verschiedene Komponenten des space shuttle-Programms
wiederverwendet wurden.
Zum einem der Außentank, aber auch die Booster.
Und auch das Triebwerk-Design vom Shuttle
findet hier wieder Anwendung.
Und das Praktische an SLS, ist dass
sie modular aufgebaut ist.
Das ist jetzt die Artemis I Konfiguration,
aber in einer späteren Version
soll sie sogar bis zum Mars fliegen können.
Wir haben doch Raketen,
mit denen wir ständig Menschen zur ISS schicken.
Reichen die dann nicht auch aus?
Nee, tatsächlich nicht.
Man braucht, um bis zum Mond zu kommen,
sehr viel mehr Schub,
als nur um in den niedrigen Erdorbit zu kommen.
Um in den LEO zu kommen,
braucht man eine Geschwindigkeit von 28500 km/h.
Um den Erdorbit zu verlassen,
brauchen wir eine Geschwindigkeit von 40000 km/h.
Also, wesentlich mehr.
Dann muss mal auch abbremsen,
um in den Mondorbit einzudrehen
und wieder zurückzukommen.
Dazu brauchen wir mehr Treibstoff und klar,
mit mehr Treibstoff ist die Rakete schwerer
und es ist nochmal schwieriger
von der Erdoberfläche zu starten.
Also wir brauchen bis zum Mond eine sehr
viel leistungsstärkere Rakete als bis in den LEO.
Zur Veranschaulichung, konnte die Saturn V
bis zum 50 Tonnen Nutzlast
bis in den Mondorbit bringen.
Wäre sie allerdings nur zur ISS geflogen,
hätte sie 140 T. Nutzlast mitnehmen können.
Wir wollen ja nicht nur bis in den Mondorbit
kommen, sondern bis auf die Mond-Oberfläche
d.h. wir müssen dort auch landen
und dann sicher wieder starten
Enter Starship
Starship ist ein komplett eigenständiges System,
dass von SpaceX gerade entwickelt wird
und es besteht aus dieser Oberstufe und Kapsel,
die wir hier sehen und das ganze
wird von einer Mega-Rakete in den Erd-Orbit gebracht
und zwar von der Falcon Superheavy.
Komplett zusammengebaut mit dem Starship
wird sie sogar größer sein als die Saturn V sein,
120 m hoch sein, fast 5000 T. wiegen beim Start
und kann eine Nutzlast
von 100 bis 150 T. bis auf den Mond transportieren.
Also genug um Sachen für eine Mondkolonie
dorthin zu bringen.
Das Starship ist komplett wiederverwendbar.
V.a. der Superheavy, die erste Stufe,
soll innerhalb einer Stunde wiederverwendbar sein.
Und der Schub soll doppelt so groß sein
wie der des SLS, sagt zumindest Elon Musk.
Wie schafft es das Starship so riesige Nutzlasten
bis zum Mond zu befördern?
Dazu benutzen wir einen Trick:
Nach dem Start, nachdem die Unterstufe wieder
sicher auf der Erde gelandet ist
wird der obere Teil mit Treibstoff betankt
und zwar im Erdorbit von einem anderen Starship,
das dort stationiert ist.
Und so kann es dann voll betankt seine Reise
Richtung Mond oder später Richtung Mars antreten.
Für die Mondlandung wird gerade jetzt
eine spezielle Version des Starships entwickelt:
Das HLS, das Human Landing System
und man sieht schon, das ist keine normale
Rakete-Oberstufe mehr, sondern das Ding hat Füße.
Es muss ja auf dem Mond landen
und einen Aufzug in dem die Astronauten
und dann von der Kapsel bis runter auf den Mond
und auf die Oberfläche gebracht werden.
Das Coole ist jetzt, dass das ganze Ding
auf dem Mond landen wird
und das ganze Ding ist riesig, nämlich 50 m hoch
und dazu, ganz grob im gleichen Maßstab,
kann man natürlich die Apollo-Landefähre nehmen
und im Vergleich ist sie winzig klein
und bei Apollo ist auch nur
der obere Teil wiedergestartet.
Hier müssen wir dann die ganze Rakete wieder
zurück in den Mondorbit starten
und dann werden die Astronauten mit dem Starship
wieder im Mondorbit in die Orion-Kapsel verfrachtet
und rein theoretisch könnte dieses Starship
im Mondorbit warten, dort wieder betankt werden
und wenn das nächste Orion-Starship kommt,
die nächste Ladung Astronauten zum Mond bringen.
Irgendwann wird es sogar möglich sein,
dass es einen regelrechten Pendelbetrieb macht
und zwar von der Mondoberfläche bis zum Lunar Gateway.
Das Lunar Orbital Plattform Gateway wird
der Ersatz für die internationale Raumstation ISS
allerdings nicht im niedrigen Erdorbit,
sondern im Mondorbit.
Ähnlich wie die ISS, ist das Lunar Gateway
eine internationale Partnerschaft.
Neben der NASA sind auch die Kanadier,
die Japaner und die Europäer beteiligt.
Die Russen allerdings sind 2021 ausgestiegen.
Das Gateway soll ähnlich wie die ISS jetzt
ein Forschungslabor sein,
aber auch als Basis für Mondmissionen dienen.
Ein Problem dabei ist tatsächlich,
dass die Strahlenbelastung im Mondorbit
sehr viel höher ist als im niedrigen Erdorbit
und deswegen wird die Station nicht durchgängig besetzt sein.
Möglicherweise kann das L. Gateway als Basis für
Flüge weiterhinaus in den Weltraum genutzt werden
z.B. Flüge zum Mars.
2024 soll es los gehen.
Da sollen die beiden ersten Module des L. Gateway
in den Mondorbit gebracht und dort zusammengebaut werden.
Gestartet werden sollen sie mit einer
Falcon Heavy-Rakete.
Die ist nicht ganz so leistungsstark wie das Starship
oder das SLS, aber es sind keine Menschen an Bord
Das heißt man kann einen Niedrig-
Energietransfer nutzen
der verbraucht weniger Energie,
wie der Name schon sagt
dauert aber ein bisschen länger.
Für die Maschinen: Kein Problem.
Wie soll es jetzt weitergehen?
Mit der Artemis III sollen die ersten Menschen
wieder auf dem Mond landen.
Mit den folgenden Artemis-Mission
soll das Lunar Gateway ausgebaut werden
und, besonders spannend, es soll
nach und nach ein Mondhabitat errichtet werden.
Dort würden zeitweise Menschen wohnen,
forschen können
und das Ganze wäre auch eine Teststation
für eine mögliche spätere Mission zum Mars.
Über einige der Schwierigkeiten bei einer
möglichen Mars-Mission haben wir ein Video gemacht,
das kommt bald raus.
Das Mondhabitat wäre wahrscheinlich
in der Südpolregion des Mondes
denn da gibt es immer Sonnenlicht und
in einigen Kratern wurde gefrorenes Wassereis gefunden,
was für die Menschen verwendet werden könnte,
aber auch zur Treibstoffgewinnung.
Die NASA hat auch den kommerziellen Nutzen im Blick
v.a. wenn man Richtung Russland oder China schielt.
Es ist für die Amerikaner wichtig
zuerst am Mond zu sein
und dort einen Mondstation aufzubauen.
Das finde ich ganz interessant.
Das Apollo-Programm war so schnell und erfolgreich
weil die Amerikaner vor der damaliger UDSSR
einen Menschen auf dem Mond landen wollten.
[Kennedy] We choose to go to the moon
in this decade and do the other things.
not because they are easy,
but because they are hard.
[Speaker]
Apollo did more than reach for the future:
It refreshed our spirits and heighted our awareness
of the human potential.
For the US Apollo provided unique confidence.
they have given us resolve, resources and commitment
of our free people,
the US can lead mankind
in the great adventure of space exploration.
Und auch jetzt wird das Artemis-Programm forciert,
weil eben der Druck da ist von der Konkurrenz.
Das sind v.a. die Chinesen, die in 20-30
Jahren auch eine eigene Mondkolonie planen.
Trotz aller Konkurrenz hinkt,
wie bei solchen Projekten üblich,
die Entwicklung der Planung hinterher.
Aber, so langsam kommt Fahrt in die ganze Sache
Noch dieses Jahr soll das Starship
seinen ersten Orbitalflug antreten.
In den nächsten 2 bis 3 Jahren sollen die ersten
Module des L. Gateway in den Mond-Orbit gebracht werden.
und Artemis I soll sehr bald starten.
Ich träume v.a. Dingen von den längerfristigen
Perspektiven, von einem Lunar Village
wo Zivilisten und professionelle Astronauten
zusammen friedlich auf dem Mond leben.
Mit Artemis I fällt nichts weniger als der
Startschuss für die erste menschliche Siedlung
auf einem anderen Himmelskörper.
In diesem Sinne wünsche ich Artemis I
"Clear Skies"!